c'est le risque de pénurie alimentaire
notamment de céréales des millions de
tonnes de blé sont bloqués dans les
ports ukrainiens le protectionnisme d1
les spéculations des autres font flamber
les prix doit-on craindre des émeutes de
la faim avant d'en débattre un premier
constat avec aurélien romano sommes nous
à la veille d'une nouvelle crise
alimentaire c'est la crainte exprimée
par le fmi car le marché du blé
notamment fait face à de multiples
difficultés fin 2021 les stocks mondiaux
commencent à diminuer suite à l'effet
couplée d'une forte demande mondiale
d'un côté et d'une production assez
médiocre en amérique du nord de l'autre
la guerre en ukraine vient donc
compliqué un marché déjà tendu par la
période qui s'ouvre était plus automne
les blés russes et ukrainiens on
représente une part très importante des
exportations la russie plus ukraine ce
après un tiers du marché mondial mais ça
sans licence sur une année ce qui est
important de rappeler c'est que la
russie puisse ukraine sur les mois
allant de juillet à octobre c'est
généralement 60 % du marché mondial cet
expert en produits agricoles souligne
aussi la troisième difficulté la
sécheresse dans de nombreux pays affecte
les récoltes à venir en inde par exemple
le gouvernement a décidé de stopper les
exportations afin de pouvoir être en
mesure de répondre à la demande
intérieure
ces mauvaises récoltes avec toute une
partie de la planète
du sud en fait on se rend compte que ces
honneurs ont connu aussi des récoltes
très faible on peut estimer que ces deux
récoltes les plus faibles depuis depuis
près de 15 ans ce qui met encore en
cours plus à risques ces pays qui sont
très dépendants du blé et notamment du
blé aussi d'un port donc toutes ces
zones on y ajoutant aussi l'afrique
subsaharienne sondés sont des zones qui
aujourd'hui seront soit extrêmement
risque
parce que nous les fait effet mauvaises
productions plus effet prix
historiquement élevé des prix élevés et
une mauvaise production ajoutons et prix
des carburants en hausse et des coûts de
transport très élevé ce sont toutes les
caractéristiques qui ont mené aux crises
alimentaires de 2008 et aux émeutes de
la faim le fmi tire donc la sonnette
d'alarmé notamment pour l'afrique
subsaharienne où le blé est importé à
85%
voilà où ils risquent des modes
alimentaires mais aussi l'utilisation
par vladimir poutine de cette arme que
représentent les tensions sur le marché
notamment des céréales on en débat tout
de suite avec lucile grosjean bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes directrice déléguée
générale chargée des plaidoyers à action
contre la faim quant à mathieu bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes chef
économiste de la coopération agricole
anthony bellanger journaliste
spécialiste des questions
internationales sur france inter bonsoir
anthony est heureux de vous retrouver
laëtitia cru pas éditorialiste politique
est resté à mes côtés évidemment je
propose pour commencer de regarder
ensemble à une du quotidien britannique
dee économistes de coming foudre
catastrophe la catastrophe alimentaire
s'annonce avec vous le voyez peut-être
pas très bien mais des têtes de mort
dans les épi de blé c'est de ça dont on
parle lucile grosjean de celles et ceux
qui vont mourir de la faim combien de
personnes sont concernées est ce qu'on
peut évaluer ça c'est peut-être facile
facile c'est effectivement pas si facile
mais il ya par exemple un rapport qui
est sorti il ya quelques jours qui parle
de 193 millions de personnes qui sont en
situation de crise alimentaire et ça
c'était pour 2021 c'était un état des
lieux 2021 donc ce avant la guerre entre
l'impact de la crise iranienne ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui c'est vraiment une
multiplication à l'échelle planétaire
des crises alimentaires dans plusieurs
plusieurs régions du monde au sahel en
afghanistan ou au yémen etc et la guerre
en ukraine bien y ajouter une couche
additionnel de choc sur une situation
qui était déjà extrêmement compliqué et
effectivement on craint le secrétaire
général des nations unies parler d'un
ouragan de famine
cette une de the economist effectivement
et cette dernière information
l'agencement fraises qui nous donne
effectivement cette réaction de de l'onu
qui réclame une aide immédiate pour
aider la corne de l'afrique donc c'est
ethiopie kenya landais on est dans cette
région 18 millions de personnes déjà
touchées par la sécheresse quant à
mathieu il
ya une notion d'urgence oui on peut dire
ça tout à fait mais vraiment innocent
d'urgence on parlait tout à l'heure
justement de ces chics sont sortis
récemment mais si on regarde plus
attentivement notamment un dernier
rapport de la fao qui a été publié au
début du mois de mai on estime qu'il ya
environ un peu plus de 500 millions de
personnes aujourd'hui qui sont dans un
état d'insécurité alimentaire et selon
les différents niveaux de stade et
différents niveaux critiques on estime
qu'il y aurait environ 400 millions de
personnes qui seraient un état d'urgence
absolue donc état d'urgence absolue mais
mais ça veut dire que c'est vraiment
beaucoup plus pardon c'est un peu c'est
pas cynique mais bon on parle de
chiffres mais je rappelle que derrière
ça il ya évidemment des enfants des
femmes et des familles c'est bien pire
que ce qu'on pouvait dire il ya deux ans
trois ans il ya vraiment une aggravation
de l'urgence alors la sécurité
alimentaire en fait on remarquer que
depuis environ l'année 2015 2016 qui
avait une remontée au fur et à mesure de
la sécurité alimentaire mondiale en fait
la sécurité alimentaire mondiale a été
significativement réduite ces dernières
années avec l'élimination de certaines
poches de pauvreté notamment en asie
notamment avec le développement de la
chine sauf que ça a mis de côté aussi
des autres poches d'insécurité
alimentaire qui l ont continué de
progresser de s'alimenter et on a même
vu certains pays sur cinq continents
comme le venezuela avec la crise
économique il a aussi a basculé dans les
état d'insécurité sociale et aussi
certaines poches d'insécurité
alimentaire et en fait on a bien vu
qu'avec aussi l'urgence climatique à
l'heure actuelle les incidents
climatiques et problématiques de
développement qui ont été aussi mis de
côté dans les pays d'afrique
subsaharienne on revient qu'aujourd'hui
dès que les équilibres des marchés
mondiaux deviennent relativement
instable tout de suite c'est une
étincelle qui embrase à l'heure actuelle
les équipes qui étaient jusqu'ici mais
sous tapis qui anthony bellanger comment
vous analyser ce qui se passe en ce
moment est peut-être si on se projette
un peu plus loin se dire que ça risque
de s'aggraver gc ca alors ce kid
absolument exceptionnel en ce moment et
pour les six mois qui viennent c'est pas
tellement le fait qu'il y ait des poches
de d'insécurité alimentaire parce que ça
a priori les agences de l'onu les
associant telle que la vôtre savent
traiter au cas par cas théron c'est
intervenir dans telle et telle région
quand il y a un problème de l'insécurité
alimentaire c'est ce qui fait que par
exemple depuis trente ou quarante ans ne
peut plus parler de famine dans le monde
c'est parce qu'on sait intervenir un peu
l'art un peu là et on s'est mobilisé à
la fois les fonds de l'onu leur capacité
d'intervention et les associations qui
savent sur le terrain se déployer pour
pouvoir le régler le problème c'est que
là on a affaire à une insécurité
alimentaire qui est d'ordre mondial
c'est à dire que vous avez partout dans
le monde des pays qui voit le prix des
matières premières de première nécessité
augmentent et et d'user de façon égale
kim est en insécurité alimentaire des
pans entiers de leur population et ce de
manière absolument extensive ce qui
signifie sa part pour le coup le système
ne sait pas faire c'est à dire jeu il y
a nous avons réglé les problèmes les uns
après les autres nous avons réglé les
problèmes à droite et à gauche mais pas
ensemble en même temps je vous donnais
juste un chiffre il y à 50 pays dans le
monde qui dépendent pour un tiers de
leurs l'approvisionnement alimentaire de
la russie et de l'ukraine 1 50 pays qui
donc demain vont payer l'ordre parce que
c'est pas forcément un problème de
stocks c'est un problème de prix vont
payer alors qu'ils n'ont pas forcément
les moyens c'est pas ces produits
alimentaires beaucoup plus cher risquent
de se retrouver sans argent pour le
faire ou sans possibilité de
subventionner ces produits et donc
d'avoir une population une part
importante de leur population dans 50
pays différents dans le monde de
l'amérique latine surtout douala en
afrique mais aussi en asie pour
incapable de pouvoir assumer ces coûts
et donc qu'ils vont devoir à faire appel
tous en même temps à ces fameuses
agences qui on sent pourtant de grandes
réussites mais qui sont vous le disions
dizaine ou même au bout de leur logique
oui ça veut dire les cibles aux gens que
vous ne pourrez pas suivre voilà on est
effectivement confronté à une telle
l'immensité des besoins partout sur la
planète qu'il ya aussi nos limites en
terme de deux capacités tout simplement
il ya une problématique aussi de
financements pour faire face à ces
crises je crois qu'il demande est
aujourd'hui aux alentours de 40
milliards globale ce qui nous sommes
énormes quand même pour faire face à ces
à ces crises alimentaires il ya 5 % qui
a été et qui a été rassemblé à l'heure
actuelle donc on est très loin du compte
même pour pouvoir commencer à délivrer
là dessus aussi ce que je voulais
souligner en rebondissant sur ce que
vous disiez c'est que on est aussi dans
un système alimentaire justement très
mondialisé et on en est à sa troisième
grande crise alimentaire mondiale qui
arrive ça montre aussi les limites de ce
système alimentaire extrême mondialisé
où il ya des dépendances énorme avec
effectivement là en l'occurrence deux
pays qui sont raides et très fort
producteurs et du coup c'est un impact
sur tous les autres d'où l'intérêt de
développer une agriculture plus local
évidemment on parlait de ça je rappelle
quelques chiffres vous l'avez évoqué
rapidement anthony l'ukraine est un on
peut dire un géant agricole quatrième
exportateur mondial de céréales
troisième exportateur de blé si on se
concentre sur le commerce mondial de blé
la russie et l'ukraine l2 représente 1/3
enfin 30 % du commerce mondial de blé et
puis à ce chiffre sur la quantité de blé
bloqués dans les ports ukrainiens on
parle de 20 millions de tonnes
ce qu'il faut dire quant à mathieu sait
que les pays qui ont représente et tous
qui pourrait représenter une alternative
ont eux mêmes des difficultés c'est ça
oui tout à fait alors on a un exemple
qui a fait parler beaucoup de lui ces
derniers temps c'est le cas de l'inde
notamment ti se retrouver assez de façon
à sectionner la face à un niveau de
production record en sept campagnes de
21 d'une 22e avec moi dire 10 millions
de tonnes supplémentaires par rapport à
ce qu'elle produit habituellement et
donc le gouvernement indien s'est
positionné au début dans une position de
force en disant qu'ils allaient pouvoir
couvrir en partie les denrées qui
n'était pas expédier de l'ukraine sauf
que si on se replonge un peu plus dans
l'histoire de l'inde on sait que c'est
un pays qui a subi de très fortes crises
alimentaires de très fortes familles qui
ont profondément marqué les politiques
mises en place et l'inde appliquez
habituellement une politique de contrôle
des exportations et de constitution de
stocks stratégiques donc c'était assez
étonnant quand même de voir l'un de se
positionner sur le marché exportateurs
il faut croire que les réalités
économiques écrit en est fier aussi
voilà les ont ramenés à la réalité tant
est que l'inde a subit une sécheresse
absolument terrible est que le pays
pourra peut-être confrontés là aussi à
la sécurité alimentaire peut
effectivement avec ces images qui
deviennent du port de kandla on est donc
en inde 4000 camions de blé qui ont été
bloqués
new delhi a décidé c'était samedi
d'interdire l'exportation qui était
prévu ça provoque est d'ailleurs là
cette réaction du ministre allemand de
l'agriculture c'était à l'issue d'une
réunion du juge g7 ont les coudes tout
de suite ouch
l'export
l'arrêt des exportations touche des pays
comme le bangladesh et le népal qui en
ont un besoin urgent nous recommandons
également qu'une décisions concrètes
soient prises à ce sujet lors de la
réunion des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement du g 7 ou l'inde sera
invité depuis stuttgart
nous appelons également l'inde à assumer
ses responsabilités en tant que membres
du g20 grecque sauvée laetitia oui j'ai
une petite question pour vous exprimer
vous avez parlé d'un chiffre 40
milliards qui ne sais quoi c'est pour
débloquer ce serait lourde de militaires
nécessaires mais jamais rien fait il me
semble que ce n'est rien ces montants 1
c'est vrai mais tout de suite depuis
deux ans on a l'impression que c'est
parlant mais j'aime et c'est vrai que
quand on regarde ce qui a été débloqué
pour de cette période du coc vite par
tous les pays développés riches ça
semble dérisoire non et c'est sam est en
partie des blocs et déjà la banque
mondiale par exemple a débloqué 12
milliards et demi de dollars pour
pouvoir répondre à cette insécurité
alimentaire j'ai pas qu'ils vont prof
probablement pas le dépenser comme ça
mais où vous de le donner directement
fin cette semaine est parfaitement
réunies sable et puis on vous parlait
tout à l'heure de l'inde qui est très
intéressant c'est de voir que l'inde par
exemple est le deuxième producteur
mondial de blé ou céréales simplement
elle n'est que le huitième exportateur
c'est à dire qu'en fait un tout petit
joueur dans le dans le marché mondial de
la paix il suffit que l'un décide
d'arrêter ses exportations et on le voit
bien qu alors qu'à l'europe que ces
formations représente a priori très peu
pour faire encore pour encore faire
grimper le prix et ça peut être un gros
c'est à peut être un petit joueur au
niveau mondial mais un joueur très
important et on l'a dit avec cette
espèce de simultanéité des plats ddd
crise c'est très important par contre
pour le bangladesh quittent un pays
voisin et qui lui compte à 80% sur le
blé indien et 4 et est important aussi
pour d'autres pays du voisinage vous
voyez bien on a des espèces de crise en
cascade mais vous avez on de le
souligner 40 milliards ça paraît peu et
se passe à peine est réuni assez
rapidement d'ailleurs c'est une volonté
politique tout à fait
qu'est ce qu'on sait quant à mathieu de
l'état des stocks disponibles justement
est-ce que
tu as quoi on a les infos ou est ce que
au contraire les états pas forcément
c'est on va commencer à parler un peu de
diplomatie
des deux de l'agroalimentaire est ce que
les états gardent ces informations pour
eux alors effectivement en fait
l'information sur les stocks et
éminemment stratégique parce qu'elle a
une très forte influence sur les prix
chez derrière et sur les prix mondiaux
on voit très bien que les marchés où
vous regardez la bourse de chicago sur
les cotations céréalière justement
réagissent très vite aux différentes
annonces de marché à l'heure actuelle il
faut s'interroger d'abord sur le niveau
mondial en fait si on regarde le stop
par rapport à la consommation mondiale
on a environ 1 27% et on essaiera une
dégradation de ce ratio depuis quelques
années
pardon j'ai bien comprendre pour vous
n'allez pas trop vite on a en stock
l'équivalent de 25 % de la consommation
mondiale annuelle de blé ou de céréales
annuel de céréales de céréales les
scores serrés en règle générale et après
si on regarde on fait par pays on va
bien que les ratios sont très différents
et vous avez un acteur comme la chine
qui aujourd'hui atteint ratio notamment
sur l'ubs les deux lors de 80% la chine
en fait en l'espace de deux ans a acheté
l'équivalent de ce qu'elle a acheté ce
qu'a apporté en termes de blé en
l'espace de sept ans par de 7 ans voilà
donc vous imaginez la fois sur le marché
mondial derrière en terme d'art
évidemment alors c'est quoi ces deux là
ils sont prévoyants parce qu'ils ont une
grande population à nourrir ou alors ils
spéculent comment vous l'analysez sasp à
mon sens est pas réellement la
spéculation c'est qu'il y ait plusieurs
effets et tout d'abord aussi une autre
dans les outils de pandémie à une
épizootie en chine justement qu'ils
avaient mises à bas une partie de son
cheptel notamment son cheptel pour ça
donc qu'il faille y reconstituer le
cheptel il a fallu importer davantage de
céréales pour nourrir ses animaux et
derrière aussi c'est vrai que suite à la
pandémie il y a eu de fortes inquiétudes
en fait derrière sur la constitution de
stocks stratégiques pour pouvoir nourrir
sa population et éviter un
mécontentement social on est quand même
dans une espèce de conjonction de
mauvaise nouvelle anthony fauci aussi
l'australie qui a un gros producteur et
qui a subi des inondations majeures on a
l'impression que toutes les planètes se
déshabille du quoi vous savez ce que
c'est jacques chirac il ennuie ça vole
en escadrille et c'est vrai que c'était
un peu moins possible que
ces s'appliquait pas non plus à ça mais
c'est vrai qu'on a l'impression
effectivement voix avec l'invs avec
l'australie qu en ce moment il ya comme
une espèce de mal de mauvaises
conjonction international qui fait qu'on
a des mets mes récoltes à peu près
partout alors ce qui est très important
de comprendre c'est qu'on est dans une
période
disruptive quand on est dans une période
dans laquelle on sort de là de la
pandémie donc il ya énormément de pays
qui ont subi qui ont soit déstocker lors
leur propre leurs propres céréales en
propres stocks stratégiques qui sont en
train qui ont essayé de donner de l'air
est constitué l'un la chine a pesé
pendant longtemps sur le marché mondial
parce que je rappelle que l'augmentation
des produits de des céréales et des
produits de première nécessité ne date
pas de la raison de l'ukraine ça fait un
an depuis début 2000 21 que ça ne cesse
d'augmenter et que donc le crâne c'est
un peu le clou dans le cercueil est donc
en fait cette espèce et qu'en plus
le transport a été beaucoup perturbé
notamment du côté de la chine parle
parle parle à que vides donc on vient à
la fin d'une période compliquée où les
stocks ont étés où il des pays ont réagi
en stockant d'autres en cinq ans - ce
que j'essayais de 2 2 août faute nos
auditeurs comprennent bien fades ou
téléspectateurs comprennent bien qu'il
ne s'agit pas vraiment d'un problème de
stock mais bien un problème de prix
c'est à dire qu'en fait par exemple
l'egypte a de voter le plus gros
importateur mondial de blé a devant elle
quatre mois de stock donc elle pourra
passer l'automne l'été et pour arriver
jusqu'en automne le problème c'est que
quand elle va revenir sur le marché pour
acheter reconstituer ses stocks elle
devra l'acheter pour beaucoup plus cher
et que donc pour des pays qui n'ont pas
forcément des ressources ni pétrolière
ni gazière qui vont elles aussi augmenté
ça va devenir un vrai souci économique
bien compris un mot là-dessus oui tu ce
jeu est juste rajouté qu effectivement
aujourd'hui on fait pas face à des
pénuries aujourd'hui nous intéresse les
rennais ont fait pas face à epernay mais
par contre les gens sont incapables
d'acheter la nourriture sur les marchés
parce que c'est trop cher alors ça ça
ouvre le jeu le chapitre que je voulais
traiter maintenant et qui est vraiment
la réponse à la question qu'on se pose
dans ce débat faut-il craindre des
émeutes de la faim je foutais
effectivement cette phrase prononcée qui
nous a tous frappés par le secrétaire
général des nations unies antonio
gutiérrez écoutez le
quarante cinq pays africains et pays les
moins avancés importe au moins un tiers
de leur blé d'ukraine ou de russie 18 de
ces pays en importe au moins 50%
cela comprend des pays comme le burkina
faso l'egypte la république démocratique
du congo le liban la libye la somalie le
soudan et le yémen
nous devons tout faire pour éviter un
ouragan de famine et l'effondrement du
système alimentaire mondial
un ouragan de famine est ce que cet
ouragan de famine peut se transformer en
émeutes de la faim laeticia je commence
avec vous vous êtes intéressé à cette
expression émeutes de la faim qui
revient dans le débat oui parce qu'à
part la période 2007-2008 on le verra
plus tard dans l'émission où cette
expression a fait référence c'est vrai
qu'au cours des 40 voire 50 dernières
années elle a été délaissé au profit de
terme plus générique comme la famine qui
était souvent associés vous en souvenez
certainement parce que nous étions
enfants ajustement des images de
personnes et souvent d'enfants dénutris
qui venaient d'afrique mais qui
finalement resté relativement passif
encore une fois dans la dénomination qu
aux émeutes de la faim thomas ça vient
c'est l'expression contemporaine
finalement des révoltes frime en terre
qui ont existé dès la rome antique et
qui ont rythmé toute l'histoire de
france alors on va pas revenir à y faire
elle est trop trop loin mais par exemple
dans la mémoire collective sont restés
des jacqueries paysanne du 14e siècle et
plus récemment bien sûr et peut-être
plus connu par l'ensemble des français
la révolution sur 16 avec ce mot de
marie antoinette qui est resté comme
quand il a été pris voilà le mot un peu
la punchline du pouvoir déconnecté
devant le peuple affamé s'ils n'ont pas
de pain qu'ils mangent de la brioche
voilà ce qui aurait dit marie antoinette
aucune biographie aucune source
historique marlier cette phrase à
marie-antoinette elle est apparue cette
phrase 54 ans après les faits donc vous
voyez que elle fait partie du compte un
peu de la légende urbaine mais si je
fais ce détour historique c'est pour
éclairer le sens de cette expression
émeutes de la faim qui revient
aujourd'hui dans le débat politique et
qui présuppose que le peuple se
retournerait contre le pouvoir en place
et donc on ne serait plus dans ce
contexte de famine qui finalement aussi
laissé entendre une certaine fatalité
donc en ce qui concerne la crise
actuelle la guerre en ukraine si des
émeutes vont avoir lieu en tout cas si
ce vocabulaire et ce mot revient dans le
débat peut-être qu'il y a une certaine
fragilité du pouvoir politique en place
des pouvoirs politiques bien plus que
peut-être des projets en tout cas actuel
de population qui serait sous le joug de
la reine lucile grosjean vous nous
l'avez dit pour l'instant il ya des
stocks a pas de pénurie vous ne voyez
pas de pénurie sur le terrain mais est
ce que pour autant vous anticipez vous
l'hypothèse d' émeutes de la faim dans
alors comme l'a expliqué un peu anthony
pter dans plusieurs mois finalement oui
ou même parfois peut-être moins dedans
plus
parce qu'effectivement quand on a quand
on a faim on a à peu près à tous de
manière de manière générale juste oui il
ya des stocks mais c'est trop cher donc
on n'y est pas donc c'est déjà une
situation on a vu déjà mais n'y a pas
très longtemps au nigeria dans certains
endroits où on travaille du fait en gros
de l'augmentation notamment des prix des
deux de l'aide humanitaire notamment du
programme alimentaire mondial zaïdi
réduire les distributions qu'ils aient
ya eu des manifestations dans les camps
de dans les camps de déplacés etc en
deux camps de réfugiés parce qu'ils
n'avaient plus accès à la nourriture
comme il avait avant donc ça peut aller
très très vite c'est ces phénomènes
lents je veux juste revenir aussi quand
même sur bien sûr il ya l'enjeu des
émeutes de la faim mais l'enjeu tout
simplement de la faim il ya eu une
famine par exemple en
2011-2012 en somalie il ya eu deux cent
mille morts donc ces femmes insee c'est
absolument énorme et massif en termes
d'impact humain que ça peut avoir donc
bien sûr c'est ça la première chose
qu'il faut qu'il faut éviter après ça
peut grade et il y aura peut-être à bon
effectivement des systèmes d'émeutes de
la faim mais ce qui nous inquiète mais
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment la situation
des gens et comment on va essayer de
protéger leur accès à l'alimentation
alors si on emploie cette terminologie
c'est évidemment parce qu'on a tous en
tête et alexandre poussin peut nous
rejoindre cette crise alimentaire des
années 2007 2008 alexandre louis thomas
il ya quinze ans il y avait huit cent
cinquante millions de personnes
sous-alimentées dans le monde avec comme
aujourd'hui est bien une conjonction de
facteurs d'abord la sécheresse dans
certains pays producteurs de céréales
des producteurs importants comme
l'australie aps ensuite à l'époque une
demande mondiale alimentaire en forte
hausse avec la chine qui se met à manger
de plus de viande et puis des capacités
de production des sols qui atteignent
leurs limites avec une agriculture
moderne très exigeante pour les sols à
cela on ajoute un peu de spéculation sur
les marchés financiers sur les matières
premières et les aliments et puis le
prix du baril de pétrole est également
forte hausse début 2008 le prix du baril
est à 100 dollars est la conséquence de
cette flambée du pétrole c'est que les
pays riches et bien il se dirige vers
les biocarburants pour trouver une
énergie moins chère avec un chiffre en
2008 30% de la production mondiale de
maïs sert à la production
de biocarburants et pas à l'alimentation
donc forcément ça provoque une hausse
des prix des céréales sur cette période
2007 2008 par exemple le prix du blé a
doublé le prix du riz est à l'époque le
plus élevé depuis 10 ans et le prix du
soja est le plus élevé depuis 34 ans est
donc cette hausse des prix des céréales
provoque des émeutes de la faim
violentes dans plusieurs pays dans le
monde comme le mexique l'argentine
l'indonésie l'algérie l'egypte et puis
ça à boutiers à des situations de famine
ou de grave insécurité alimentaire
notamment dans les pays africains comme
le soudan le tchad le congo la chine est
également touchée à l'époque et puis ça
a des conséquences géopolitiques
cette crise alimentaire c'est l'une des
raisons des printemps arabes qui ont
déstabilisé certains régimes politiques
comme en egypte ou en tunisie en 2011 et
cette crise alimentaire elle dure avec
des répliques jusqu'en 2013 merci
beaucoup alexandre pour ce rappel
historique quant à mathieu dernier
élément delà de la chronique des
licences ça peut durer hier que est-ce
qu'on est ce qu'on peut et va lever
parce que voilà la nature à des cycles
l'agriculture voilà ce sont des sites
qu'on connaît est ce que cette période
de tension au delà de la ce qui se passe
en ukraine est ce que ça peut durer ça
va dépendre de deux facteurs à mon sens
tout d'abord du bon vouloir de la
dernière poutine vis-à-vis de l'essayer
de ces décisions d'orientation stratégie
de vouloir continuer de livrer des pays
importateurs car il a lui-même signalé
en disant que ceux qui seraient ils en
premier ce serait d'abord des pays
alliés rallier derrière la bannière en
tout cas est derrière le l'historique on
va dire russe et sur le son histoire
aujourd'hui du conflit avec l'ukraine
qui nous étonne même pas conflit
d'ailleurs et opérations militaires et
d'autre part on voit bien que
aujourd'hui donc bien poutine à la
crainte qu'elles sortent le doigt sur la
gâchette aujourd'hui alimentaire c'est
une arme c'est une arme la nuit armes
l'alimentation est toujours de toute
manière au coeur des stratégies
militaires ont loi très bien du
différents traités qu'il est au courant
du sexe passera six militaires
l'alimentation est toujours au coeur il
faut nourrir des armées on peut affamer
des hommes et des armées adverses on
peut négocier l'alimentaire pour pouvoir
obtenir des concessions donc on voit
bien que l'ania poutine va utiliser
socim et on pourrait peut-être se
positionner dans moi ce que j'appelle
peut-être un nouveau rideau de fer
alimentaire dont c'est à dire que
peut-être qu'on va retourner vers nous
clivage aujourd'hui mondiale ou des pays
vont devoir s'aligner derrière la russie
au détriment des relations qu'ils
peuvent avoir avec le monde occidental
on le voit déjà aujourd'hui une certaine
façon il ya des pays qui sont dans une
forme de neutralité ou qui ne se
positionne pas contre l'invasion de
l'ukraine pour ne pas fâcher vladmir
poutine on l'a vu lors de vote la
résolution de l'onu justement où on voit
bien qu'une partie des pays du
tiers-monde ne se sont pas alignés
derrière ils préfèrent rester notre
vis-à-vis du conflit pour éviter toute
tension avec leur principal fournisseur
aujourd hui de céréales qui est la
russie san antonio s'est pas tout à fait
c'est vrai mais on peut tout à fait
juste aidé à par exemple n'y a aucun
pays d'afrique n'est suivie même le mali
même le glandeur la centrafrique d'un
suivi l'a suivi la russie dans son
actualité non les gens je dis non c'est
quoi ces îles ont choisi une forme de
neutralité soit ils ont soit ils ont
voté la résolution qui condamne l
invasion de l'ukraine se sont ils se
sont abstenus moi mais je ne peux pas
injurier l'avenir l'inde et la chine en
fait on l'analyse de l'inde et la chine
sait c'est pas forcément un calcul sur
la sécurité alimentaire c'est plus un
calcul sur le pétrole et le gaz d'une
part et d'autre part sur le fait que
c'est encore les européens qui se tapent
dessus par contre c'est vrai et là vous
avez mille fois raison qui s'en sert
comme une arme en fait la lumière
poutine a fait 3 calculs avant de lancer
son adhésion de l'ukraine d'une part que
l'europe était épuisée par le quoi qu'il
en coûte après la peau de la pandémie
coville et que nous serions bien
incapable d'imposer des sanctions
économiques en plus il ya les encore en
plus aggravé notre crise économique
d'autre part que ne supporteront pas
cinq à six millions de réfugiés
l'ukrainien enfin en europe il avait
pensé que comme de la même manière nous
n'avons pas supporter quelques milliers
soulève en biélorussie qui tentait de
traverser la frontière biélorusse avec
la avec la pologne que 5 millions ce
serait trop et que nous sommes nous
croulons riom sous les réfugiés se
serait pas possible et il a fait le
calcul aussi qu' il briserait l'entente
une certaine de d'unanimité autre point
d'entente mondial au travers de larmes
delà du blé et des céréales sur les deux
premiers calculs on a bien vu qu'il a
tort il s'agit donc pour la communauté
internationale de ne lui donner tort sur
le troisième calcul et c'est vrai que là
pour le coup le facteur temps compte
énormément
parce qu' il s' il empêche par exemple
la récolte ukrainienne de sortir en juin
je parle bien le genre dans quelques
semaines juin juillet ou de celle qui a
été planté et qui doit normalement ça
être exporté oui ça perturberait les
marchés mondiaux mais encore une fois
vous le disiez vous même c'est
représente assez peu d'argent c'est à
dire qu'on peut résister à ce troisième
calcul de disruption ou d'armes
utilisées par des appareils en protéines
à peu de compte 40 milliards d'euros
c'est à la portée de n'importe quelle
économie occidentale oui alors tout le
monde l'a compris et notamment emmanuel
macron qui en appelait récemment à la
responsabilité de vladimir poutine
c'était le 24 mars dernier après les
sommets du g7 puis de l'otan à bruxelles
on écoute le prêt dans la république la
guerre en ukraine rend impossible pour
le moment par le choix fait par la
russie de ce mets comme il se devrait et
donc est en train de créer une situation
qui sera encore plus grave dans 12 à 18
mois
cette situation va créer une crise
alimentaire des situations humanitaires
gravissime dans plusieurs pays et à coup
sûr des conséquences politiques massives
dans plusieurs des pays que j'évoquais
mais il est absolument impérieux que au
delà du cessez le feu
la russie se montrent responsables et ne
prennent pas en plus
justement cette responsabilité de créer
cette famine qui sinon il est à coup sûr
inéluctable quant à mathieu je reviens
vers vous sur l' usage de vladimir
poutine de cette arme quelles sont les
différentes stratégies en sa possession
déjà il ya une arme quand on fait honte
et qu'on la voit pas tout de suite non
le vois très bien aujourd'hui sur nos
factures d'énergie c'est le gaz par
exemple le coût énergétique derrière
pour la production agricole aujourd'hui
s'envole on le voit bien aujourd'hui
pour les pays occidentaux et surtout si
on remonte jusqu'à l'extrême amont
notamment le prix les anglais on le voit
aujourd'hui augmente de façon
exponentielle que sont des engrais
azotés pour les 15 a besoin de gaz
exactement et je passe aussi le fait que
l'on achète des produits intermédiaires
auprès la russie notamment des matières
chimiques pour pouvoir produire ces
anglais donc le fait est que aujourd'hui
on se retrouve encore face à une impasse
parce qu'on a encore les moyens de payer
mais pour les pays par contre ils sont
beaucoup plus fragiles en termes de
ressources financières on voit bien
qu'il pourrait peut-être y avoir une
incapacité à lire pour la prochaine
récolte à venir et cela en fait cela ou
quand vous disiez justement sur quel pas
de temps cela va encore durer on voit
bien que il ya le temps immédiat le
temps de la stratégie militaire mais il
ya également aussi le temps de la
stratégie derrière alimentaires et d'une
stratégie à mon sens de déstabilisation
qui s'étale au contraire sur plusieurs
mois on va on va ouvrir sur dans un
instant sur les solutions possibles
notamment sur l'europe et c'est enfin le
pas seulement l'europe essaye de mettre
en place deux coalitions intitulé farm
mais je voudrais quand même si grosjean
qu'on recompte dynamo de la spéculation
il ya aussi de la spéculation qui est à
l'oeuvre et qui est un facteur
évidemment aggravant tout à fait basescu
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur le
fait qu'il n'y a pas de pénurie en soit
pour le moment et c'est plutôt une peur
sur les marchés qui fait de sa spéculé
que les prix les prix augmentent donc
réussir à réguler davantage ses marchés
agricoles notamment pour pour baisser
ces phénomènes de spéculation est aussi
en relation des stocks pour faire
baisser les prix et en parlant de la
chine tout à l'heure des stock
impressionnant de la sinne pardon nous
interrompre mais la chine pourrait jouer
un rôle par exemple on l'a fait il met
d'ailleurs si on se place du côté
chinois ça serait même un argument
diplomatique ou peut-être même d un
argument économique pour gagner des
marchés vous voyez ce que je veux dire
de débloquer une partie de ces céréales
pour les pays qui en ont le plus besoin
encore une fois le jeu parce que le pont
aussi c'est que on produit aujourd'hui
sur la planète bien assez de nourriture
pour nourrir l'ensemble de la planète et
est bien plus en l'occurrence c'est
plutôt un problème de répartition et
c'est un problème d'utilisation de cette
alimentation la moitié en gros de ce
qu'on produit va vers l'alimentation
animale il ya une partie on parle et à
l'heure de de ce qui était utilisé vers
les agrocarburants et aussi quelle
qu'elle soit on fait
pour dans nos choix d'alimentation et
qu'est ce qui va vers l'alimentation
humaine est ce que je termine là dessus
et ensuite vraiment on parle de ce
programme phare mais est-ce qu'il peut y
avoir un axe quant à mathieu moscou
pékin sur les céréales un
lin fournissant l'autre basse et plus ou
moins on va dire se passeront quand ce
qui se passait mais on voit bien que les
relations économiques et notamment déjà
les relations en termes énergétiques
il ya un contrat aidé par un accord qui
a été conclu de très longue durée et on
voit bien que la russie se tournent
aujourd'hui vraiment à l'est derrière et
pourrait effectivement utiliser le canal
chinois derrière pour inonder ou
importer une menace vis à vis
aujourd'hui des pays qui achètent du bo
prélat réussi en disant que nous allons
d'abord livré notre partenaire chinois
sauf que le problème c'est que là il ya
toujours montré peur de la chine parce
qu'il ya une relation de défiance
relation des sciences mais ils ont très
peur de tomber de devenir les frais al
delà des chinois parce que d'un côté
vous avez un milliard 400 millions
d'habitants et une économie qui est
clairement la deuxième au monde alors
que la russie n'est absolument pas de
nox pas du tout la même catégorie et
donc les russes depuis toujours et en
tout cas depuis 30 ans bien compris que
la nouvelle puissance économique au
monde se trouvait à leurs frontières
4000 km de frontière avec la chine ils
n'ont pas du tout envie de devenir les
les juniors partenaires de la chine donc
on voit bien que leur intérêt est à la
fois effectivement des manière immédiate
effectivement de tenter d'expliquer que
mais puisque c'est comme ça puisque
l'europe ne veut pas de nous on va se
tourner vers les chinois et ils sont en
fait excusez moi l'expression péter de
trouille à l'idée de devoir vendre tous
leurs pétrole tout leur gaz et surtout
leur matière première à une chine qui en
a extrêmement enfants lucile grosjean ce
programme donc farm c'est quoi c'est une
coalition qui se met en place entre elle
et qu'elle est l'idée ces initiatives
qui est en train de se construire il ya
plusieurs piliers intérieur de cette
initiative
l'idéal c'est que la solidarité lien les
liens à l'autre liée à
ajustement essayé de baisser ces
phénomènes de spécifier la spéculation
et le troisième liés à la production
agricole il ya des bons éléments de
grands et ses initiatives qui est en
train de passer au niveau européen il ya
aussi certains éléments qu'il faudrait
revoir comme je disais tout à l'heure
seul le fait produire plus en europe a
pas forcément résoudre une ni à court
terme ni à long terme cette situation on
est plutôt sur est réussir à pousser
réduire ces phénomènes de dépendance
justement à l'échelle à l'échelle
mondiale en soutenant plutôt le
développement de l'agriculture
d'agriculture locale par exemple sur la
solidarité c'est pas qu'une histoire de
distribuer de la nourriture c'est de
renforcer des mesures de protection
sociale pas le cas des bonnes choses
dont tu es encore en train de se
construire
ça se construit en réaction à la crise
alimentaire d'aujourd'hui où c'était une
c'est peut-être une initiative qui
précédait cette crise alimentaire pour
moi c'est une nouvelle initiative si je
raconte pas de bêtises après il ya le g7
a régulièrement pris des initiatives
pour essayer de faire face à la
situation d'insécurité alimentaire
mondial je crois que c'était en 2015 à
elmo déjà en allemagne une télé promis
d'arriver à sortir 500 millions de
personnes de la fin on voit bien que au
delà des demos à vis du mal à se mettre
en oeuvre tout cas aussi à ne point
beaucoup à pousser là dessus c'est très
bien d'annoncer des initiatives mais
l'important ça va être de délivrer en
gros et qui est vraiment quelque chose
qui se passe vrai problème en fait vous
avez c'est vraiment fascinant squeeze
parce que je le vrai problème c'est le
prix c'est à dire que vous voyez bien le
commerce mondial de blé par exemple ces
reproches c'est une toute petite
fraction de la de la production mondiale
de blé la chine est la première est le
premier producteur de blé au monde lota
de céréales au monde et n'exporte
quasiment rien et en fait le prix est
déterminé par cette petite partie du
commerce mondial le blé qui s'échangent
le blé s'échange encore il s'échange ça
représente peu delà de la production on
devrait alors oui un complice a suffi à
définir les prix pour l'ensemble de la
production mondiale de blé il ya bien
longtemps un aspect effectivement
comment dire qu'il va falloir à un
moment réguler ou pas alors je donne
juste qui ce qu'on fait pour réguler ce
prix est bien on relâche sur le marché
mondial des tonnes et des tonnes de blé
américains l'ont fait avec une le
pétrole récemment on essaye de le faire
avec le gars c'est plus compliqué on
essaie de faire la paix avec le pétrole
vont faire baisser le prix du pétrole
est effectivement d'habitude on lâche
des stocks entiers de blé pour faire
baisser le prix du lait sont prévues
dans ce programme farm est entre autres
enfin et l'équipe pour l'instant ce
n'est pas parce que c'est impossible de
le mettre en place un examen très simple
c'est une raison d'accès à ces stocks
c'est à dire que vous pouvez par exemple
décider de que la chine donne une partie
des stocks et pour tout vous dire elle
va le faire c'est à dire elle peut
attendre encore un peu diplômé depuis un
moment en plein milieu de l'été elle a
annoncé qu'elle mettra à la disposition
d'une race mauvais à sauver l'afrique
est elle en a les moyens mais encore
faut-il qu'elles puissent transporter ce
blé encore faut-il que les marchés le
les marchandises puissent circuler
normalement ce qui n'est pas le cas en
ce moment le pôle port de shanghai est
entièrement bloquée par l'ape notamment
par des mesures de que vides les grands
ports mondiaux sont quasiment déshérence
en ce moment en terme de vraquiers cd en
perles de deux accords de livraison de
produits de première nécessité de ce
type vous avez plein de perturbations
qui viennent en ce moment disrupt et le
prix et même les stocks dieu que
disponible pour pour le problème pour
l'ensemble du monde quant à mathieu vous
l'avez évoqué c'est un séisme
alimentaire qui est en train de frapper
la planète et va y avoir des répliques
eric mc plusieurs plusieurs vagues c'est
ça en quelque sorte qui nous qui nous
attendent tout à fait là on voit que le
début si je me suis dit on le voit dans
nos rayons à l'heure actuelle on voit
que les prix soient des patous que des
produits de première nécessité
augmentent au fur et à mesure et on voit
qu'il ya plusieurs lames d'inflation qui
vont se confronter il ya dans l'immédiat
aujourd'hui sur le prix au marché
physique on verra si on veut
immédiatement du blé effectivement il
faut déjà payer cher mais derrière va y
avoir les coûts de production des
producteurs qui vont fortement augmenter
il va y avoir les prévisions de récolte
qui vont venir ou à bien qu'il ya des
tensions aujourd'hui sur les prochaines
récoltes aux etats-unis au brésil on
voit aussi qu'en chine il ya eu des
problèmes en train de taux d'humidité
des problèmes de sécheresse en un et on
voit bien que en fait c'est un effet
d'emballement espèces d'aci de cycle qui
va encore continuer de se faire donc on
va peut-être avoir moins de productions
à venir peut-être pas avoir les moyens
de produire opté que les élections ne
vont pas avoir les moyens d'acheter ce
qu'il faut pour produire etc etc parce
que habré c'est quoi ce sont les
filières animales qui vont qui vont être
en difficulté c'est ça aujourd'hui
filières animales sont entre le marteau
et l'enclume ce qu'on appelle un effet
de ciseaux en fait ils voient les
éleveurs aujourd'hui voient leurs
charges augmenter sur tous les postes
que ce soit le poste de l'énergie tout
ça sur le poste alimentaire et derrière
les prix à la consommation donc leur
prix de vente derrière ne mentent pas
dans les mêmes proportions donc derrière
la marche qui peuvent dégager en fait
diminué derrière c'est la pérennité de
leur activité qui est en jeu on peut
peut-être quand même donné quelques
bonnes nouvelles réserves moyen terme
espérons qu'on te regarde ce que parce
qu'ils exportent la russie en matière de
céréales elle exporte autant que l'union
européenne notant que la autant que la
canada autant que les états unis autant
que le brésil c'est en global ce qui
signifie qu'il ya dans deux notes dans
notre côté du monde des réserves à la
fois de terre et de possibilités dans
les six mois à venir pas là tout de
suite parce qu'on peut pas décider là
maintenant de planter du blé pour le
récolter est en trois mois c'est
impossible mais par contre dans les six
à neuf mois à venir on peut
effectivement de mobiliser plus de
terres en au brésil même si après
quelques problèmes en argentine
d'ailleurs les exportations de céréales
brésiliennes et argentines ont été des x
2 au mois de mars on peut le faire aussi
au canada qui est une énorme qui roman
autant de terres agricoles que la russie
on peut le faire aux états unis et on
peut le faire aussi dans l'union
européenne donc à moyen terme il y a
moyen de s'organiser pour avoir un peu
plus un peu plus de deux ans tout cas
beaucoup plus de céréales à court terme
non à court terme clairement il ya eu
une augmentation des prix parce qu'il ya
un resserrement s'appelle au bottleneck
c'est un entonnoir des prix dû parce que
là la russie et d'ukraine seront d'être
empêchés mais à moyen terme quand même
où le regard c'est quoi si moi c'est un
non six moines entre les premières les
premiers semis des premières récoltes et
les premières possible et la
disponibilité sur les marchés mondiaux
et version des variables climatiques
fausse
lucile grosjean ce que ce que vous
décriviez ce que décrivent et quant à
mathieu doute à leur sert que cet effet
de ciseaux il frappe les exploitants
français évidemment ou européens on voit
bien que les difficultés on l'a montré
plusieurs fois ici qu'elles sont
confrontées mais alors dans un pays
pauvre il faut essayer de prendre
conscience de ce que ça représente
ils sont en train de vivre aujourd'hui
bel ébat l'impact est d'autant plus
direct parce qu'il ya en général pas de
mesures de protection sociale en place
il ya pas de filets sociaux pour
protéger les gens de ces chocs dont qui
les prennent directement sa celulle
clairement le le premier point c'est
pour ça qu'on pousse beaucoup ces
mesures de protection sociale pour
essayer de protéger au maximum les gens
de tout ça et après oui on voit en ce
moment se multiplier l'estimation qui
est donné c'est qu'en gros à chaque 1%
d'augmentation des des prix ça veut dire
qu'il ya des millions de personnes qui
tombent dans la pauvreté à l'échelle
mondiale donc ça va et là on en est
aujourd'hui entre 20 et 30% en moyenne
donc donc les le phénomène est déjà
énorme elle est allée se termine
peut-être parce qu' un petit message
d'espoir quand même quant à mathieu ce
que ce qu'on appelle la grande muraille
verte dans le sahara et le sahel à
s'élancer c'est un partenariat union
européenne union africaine
alors ses envies à long terme voilà
c'est ça on est à long terme mais c'est
quand même c'est quoi c'est une autre
une solution potentielle dans dans ce
nouveau paysage géopolitique de
de l'alimentaire dont on parle et ça
serait peut-être un espoir oui en
particulier pour des zones que moi jeune
homme à haute sismicité climatique c'est
à dire des zones qui vont se retrouver
en dehors aussi des forces de marché qui
vont se construire avec des fortes
intensités de phénomènes climatiques
soient des sécheresses ou au contraire
des inondations massives donc ça peut
être peut-être effectivement une lueur
d'espoir à venir on revient que
l'urgence pour l'instant lé actuelle et
qu'il faut employer donc des moyens
opérationnels d'urgence d'avoir pour
répondre aux jouets dont on parle tant
de débloquer des enveloppes financières
et qui au final ne représente pas grand
chose par rapport à tout ce qui a pu
être dépensés pour d'autres phénomènes
où on peut même remonter à l'époque 2007
2008 seront à damier sauver des banques
de la faillite alors pu on aurait pu
peut-être sauver un des gens de la fin
un tout dernier mot anthony sur le les
conséquences peut-être écologique à
court terme d'un panier de l'europe oui
moi on peut produire plus sauf qu'on
était plutôt dans une phase avec farm
tout forte de la ferme à la fourchette
ne plus de jachère le moins deux mois de
production intensive donc faut changer
pied pour quelques peut-être un ou deux
ans il faut changer de famille messahel
a fallu en discuter avec l'arrivée
l'iphone et sur qui tout à coup ne parle
plus de ces deux céréales dépensé pour
le biocarburant alors que ça représente
quand même beaucoup de choses et qui par
contre défend l'idée qu'il faut
absolument remettre en culture kelly
fameux 4% place et donc il va falloir
repenser le modèle agricole européen ça
c'est sûr juste une petite dernière
réplique très vite les émeutes de la
faim ça arrive essentiellement les pays
où il ya à la fois des problèmes
problème de prix et un problème
gouvernementale c'est à dire qu'en fait
on fait on descend dans la rue pour se
débarrasser de son gouvernement et de
son problème de faim merci beaucoup de
ce mot de conclusion merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat